Bảo mắt mô, cơn báo thứ 1,5 đàn tiến vào vùng biển bắt bộ.
Sau khi đi vào vùng biển thấm trên biển đồng,
bảo mắt mắt mạnh lên các mềm mô,
gió 1,5 bài kilomatch trần giờ,
giật các mềm mô nguồn, dí chuyển tay tay bắt,
với tức độ 2,5 kilomatch trần giờ.
Dứ đảo, sau khi vượt bản đảo, lôi châu, chúng quốc,
báo sẽ tiến vào cuối phần giới việt chung,
với sức gió khoảng 1,5 mềm kêu lối trần giờ.
Vì xuống các bạn hãy tự tình tới.
Nào sẽ, có sự mạnh lên, khi giới vượt qua xuống,
khi mắt, của lôi châu,
và đi vào vui bộ thì tiến nhất là bảo mặt sát,
nhưng mà đất 2 cái độ đứt tỏ của lôi phần.
Anh ơi, nên là cái cơ bộ bảo vô xuống nó sẽ tạng ra,
và có lý bảo giọc, mình có khả năng kêu bảo châu bảo.
Nhưng vẫn xuống điện cái dông lốc,
ở phần trước khi các bạn gây ra thì mình tự tất lọc,
rất lớn, đối khóng gây và nhạc cửa.
Quang bây ra.
Tự đe mai, khoảng lý đến những vình gió mạnh cấp sau cấp mười,
có thể làm độ kê cối nhà cửa của đẹt.
Sau trong đất liền đồng bắt bộ, gió cấp sau cấp bây,
rất cấp tám cấp chiến.
Trước đó, miền đồng đã hướng mười kên bảo,
gần nhất là bảo buồa loài,
độ bộ 2 tiếng quang chỉ, 2 chiến tăng chiến,
xức gió cấp mười một dật mề bốn.
Bảo khiến năm mề mốt người chết,
mề bốn mất tích hơn 1 trong bề 2 nghìn môi nhà hướng,
thì thải gần mười lâm nghìn chiến 3 tỉ đồng.